content marketing must play off of
social media and take advantage of those
channels in ways that drive traffic back
to the company website prospects aren't
making purchases from your social media
profiles they're converting on your
actual website so ideally your content
should use social media as a platform
for sharing content that ultimately
drives viewers back to your company
website after completing this module you
should be able to do the following first
identify channels that matter most to
your business be it b2b or b2c second
list the benefits of YouTube Facebook
Twitter Linkedin and others and last
explain what makes good content
irresistible shareable so here's an
example of somebody who has created some
really compelling content that people
wanted to share and the thing that they
tapped into the emotion if you will that
fuel this was the emotion around the
World Cup it turns out particularly in
the world of video the audience for the
World Cup is far more passionate than
any of the audience's that you might
think of in the United States around
baseball or football or hockey or
basketball and one of the things that I
expected to happen this year that didn't
turn out to be the case
was the people who stole the world kept
four years ago will probably likely to
do it again that was Nike they created
the most compelling content around that
event but Nike got blown away
Nike ended up in second place the people
who beat Nike Dannon yogurt
oh no timeout this is around the world
cup and yogurt beats makers excuse me
where's the connection well let me tell
you this story because
this is something any Content marketer
can do and this is a lesson worth
learning Adana yogurt people I had a
brand called Activa and what they did is
they hooked up with Shakira and they
created a video called lalala which is a
song and why did they do this well it
turns out if you look at the most shared
video content of all time ninety-nine
out of a hundred of those videos are
music videos music for whatever it's
worth
taps into things that most of us content
marketers don't think we're supposed to
tap into but a yogurt could do it so why
can't we and what they did is they said
yo Shakira we're going to create this
video together and you're going to sing
lalala but you know it's going to be not
just for Activia but for a World Food
Programme it was a good cause too
because we're going to time little cause
marketing along with this whole effort
now the reason they were able to get
Shakira is she had done the official
World Cup video four years earlier but
they didn't hire her to do this year's
World Cup
so she was quote available but Activia
basically said nobody knows that really
that's inside baseball we're going to
create a video that most people are
going to think is the this year's
official video because it's got you in
it and you're from Colombia and the plan
the World Cup in South America so
there's the connection and we want you
to dance around and sing and do what you
do but you know what on behalf of our
brand or that they were really tapping
into is this phenomena of everybody
really loves and shares music videos or
if those are the most popular ones
anyway how can you wrap your brand
around that well determine that has been
coined by a company over in London
called unruly calls it track Verizon so
it's like advertising only it's a music
track
you get it whatever their kind of phrase
but what it has done is it's blurred the
line between what is a music video and
what is just really good content about a
brand and oh by the way Danny yogurt and
the only people who've done this the
people at Fiat have done it the people
at H&M have done it you know a lot of
different marketers even Volvo as like
dabbled with track vert icing and one of
the things that they have discovered is
you can steal the show because here's
the punchline Danny yogurt was not an
official FIFA sponsor they did not pay
north of 200 million dollars to become
an official sponsor they just hijacked
the show by picking up the woman who
sang the official song four years
earlier but was available and she sang
and she sang again and it was a really
great song and oh by the way there was
yogurt involved along with this good
cause the call to action in this
particular video isn't come by my yogurt
it's please come participate in this
food program so you know what that's
what I mean
about creating engaging content so this
module has been about answering the
question if you use a larger number of
social media platforms are you more
likely to be an effective content
marketer and I think the answer to this
question is well you don't have to use
every social media platform Under the
Sun you really do want to be picky and
choosey about the ones that are
effective but the real magic isn't I've
used this platform badly for corporate
propaganda it's I've used this platform
to share something that is compelling
something worth sharing something that
may actually touch an emotional nerve as
well as the logical side in the sales
process and if you do that then yes yes
it can be incredibly effective
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos to nerd out and get
certified in digital marketing click
here